Excellent.
So this was the heat armies.
Why hit or miss?
Because the ball that I throw is either below or the boss,
their function,
not what we will actually use is the sample mean sample mean is different.
I would like to integrate this function and I can take samples of it.
Sam was here mean that I have f of x and two X.
I can substitute a number and I can evaluate the function there.
So I don't know the integral of the functions too complicated,
but I can evaluate it.
I can evaluate it at zero,
at all points,
15 to and values like that.
How do I compute the actual integral from these fashion,
from this,
these samples?
Well,
we will take a look through an extremely difficult example,
which is integrating x.
Okay,
so let's,
let's solve this with multiple different methods.
Method one,
what does the mathematician do?
Find a really did function.
What is the primitive function of x x squared over two all we have to do is
substitute one and zero and therefore we get one half off.
Excellent.
So I know that I'm looking for one half.
What does the engineer do?
The engineer knows that this is a linear function.
Therefore this is going to be the area of a triangle.
What are the lengths of the triangle?
The base is one because I'm integrating from zero to one.
The height is also one
because if I go one to the right,
I'm going to go on upwards as well because this is x.
So the area of the triangle is the base times the height over two so this is one
half again.
Now we have the mathematician and the engineer.
What does Monte Carlo Guy Do?
A Monte Carlo Guy didn't study mathematics and also he can't do any of these.
So what Monte Carlo Guy is going to do is he's going to take samples of this
function.
So I evaluate f of x and o 0.2 how much is it at all point to,
well obviously or point to sip as possible.
Example,
what about a low 0.4 but at o point for this is awkward for him
and so on.
So I have taken four randomly chosen samples from dysfunction and this is called
sample beam.
This means hemorrhaging.
So let's take the average of all of these are the average of all of these
islands is exactly one half.
So this gives me the actual result for an integral than I could otherwise not
solve.
Now we can coat this very easily.
Yeah,
just a few lines of code and there's already access lines of code because of
printing and whatnot.
But you can,
we can see how small disease,
this is the actual function,
this double f that I'm interested in and f of x,
x.
So it's not really that difficult.
What is the output of this program?
After many samples,
I approach direct calls to one half up to quite a few digits.
So this works really,
really well.
Yeah.
But there's something really interesting about this.
So if I draw one sample from this Intergraph
yeah,
then I have an overestimation off the result.
Why?
Because I'm looking for all 0.5 and I have four point in December.
What about 10 samples?
Is this an overestimation or underestimation?
10 samples
wasn't paying attention to the sentence before because it was thinking about 10
samples.
Tickets,
dammit.
Okay.
So the question is,
is all points 61 more?
Nope,
I'm fine.
Yeah.
So tell us a good approximation because it's 1.6 more than what?
It's more than what?
Google workbook one five.
Yeah,
exactly.
So this is an overestimation.
Okay,
excellent.
What about 100 samples with happy hour?
Hopefully it's
almost perfect.
That's an underestimation.
Okay.
What about 1000 samples?
Who will be happy?
Well maybe may I ask her permission?
Pizza.
Her.
Okay.
Marco knows that this is an underestimation and this is a weird behavior,
right?
Because I have over estimations and underestimations of this interim role.
Okay.
But in the end it seems that they are going to,
the deviations are going to be less and less.
So this almost looks like a side.
So it's like jeopardy.
The convergence is something like a sign of x times x,
is it?
No,
because it's going to get large side effects over bags.
So this is like a sign that starts off with large deviations of large aptitude
that it gets smaller and smaller.
This is how the convergence of Monte Carlo investigators goal,
and this we call by the way still has to convergence.
So it means that it can be over and under the integral,
but as you add more samples,
it's guaranteed to be closer.
Let's have another example.
Let's integrate this function two times.
Science Square of X.
Yeah.
The function in the country,
uh,
results were,
yes,
I can do all those two samples.
What are the frequencies fight then you get to compete with them.
There's a probability to having such that once you could say that,
yes,
this can happen.
One,
that this has very low power because why would you keep the same region over and
over again?
And you can also do smart things.
Slide like putting a grid on the function and sampling that.
So that's,
that's one thing.
But
what you will see later that we'll have unbiased estimators and this means that
you can expect the error to shrink in time,
but this will be a couple lectures down the line.
This is everything fine regarding that.
That wasn't going be mark,
that's exactly how it goes.
Okay.
What does the mathematician guy,
I do look for primitive functions.
Excellent.
What is the primitive function for the science part of x?
What?
It's one half of x minus the assigned times the cold side.
Let's do the actual substitution.
We have our and Pie and apple.
What as the engineer do or these are not triangles anymore.
So you better look it up on
more from off phone and you ain't got something like this.
And there is all these again pie.
So wonderful engineering works.
Okay.
What does Monte Carlo,
I do Monte Carlo Chi doesn't the war from Alpha doesn't know math,
mathematics that doesn't know anything.
But this hat he has his 20 whatever line c pass pass program.
Okay,
let's take samples of this.
What are we looking for?
What was the number?
What was the end result?
Because pot.
Okay,
so let's substitute dysfunction.
Where this double f is now,
uh,
the science corner of X.
And I have also this multiplier of two in line 35.
So this on the right side,
you see that this is what I'm looking for.
This is what we have changed.
Not just one more time.
What?
What am I looking for?
What would be the perfect result?
Okay,
excellent.
And they run this program and it starts out maybe three dyl 3.6 okay.
And as I add more samples,
I would get one
up high.
I get one.
Okay.
So I have been lying to you.
I have been lying to you all along.
This doesn't work at all and we don't have the slightest idea why this doesn't
work.
That's one of the most important lessons during this course.
Not,
not because of this thing.
Who Cares?
We'll pull,
study this thing and then sorted out.
But you start out,
if you have a difficult problem,
you start out trying to understand it with your intuition.
You don't start throwing multidimensional in Nicole's everywhere.
You start out thinking of what is going on.
Then there is a diffuse interaction.
There is scattering in the advocacy.
How does it look like you use your intuition and your intuition can get you very
so in the integration of this f of x,
the intuition of the sample mean could,
could get us the perfect solution.
There may be more complicated cases where your intuition fails.
And this doesn't mean that intuition is not useful,
but it means that he can only take you so far.
So if you,
if you have barriers like this that you cannot go through intuition,
Dan is the point when you start using mathematics and you start to evaluate what
is going on.
You start to look at the details.
So use the intuition to get an idea of what's going on.
And then if you run into obstacles,
use mathematics to sort out the details.
That's one of the most important lessons out there for you when you will go out
there and try to study really complicated theories.
Okay,
so this doesn't work.
I have been lying to you all along.
How can we sort it out?
Well,
after the commercials with a little bit more,
the commercial will come in the form of Tomas.
Okay.
Because,
uh,
he is going to travel to Japan for a house a year long,
half year long research project.
So he has a few lectures left,
three,
all of them in particular.
And he has to hold them now because he's going to take the plane afterwards.
So the next three lectures are going to be held by thoughts and uh,
I mean the timing is a bit suboptimal because I have to cut this lecturer in
halls.
That's at least you know how Monte Carlo Integration Works and he is going to
tell you more about this.
And then we will complete the student and at the end of this unit.
So before I get too complicated,
three lectures from Thomas,
then I come back,
we complete this lecture will be know how to ride the global illumination
program.
So this is exactly what we were going to do.
I have implemented the whole global illumination.
Think it is beautiful.
It's kind of everything.
It can be too beautiful.
Indirect elimination costings.
I think it's in 250 lines.
It's readable,
it's understandable.
And many,
many people have learned how to a limitation from this program.
So after three lectures from Thomas,
then I finish this.
That's one lecture.
The next section is going to be a cold through.
So we are going to take into,
uh,
we are getting our news through the cold.
What I have really,
how this works.
How is front of House Law in sergeant here?
Where do I use house long?
How do I do all these things?
You will see everything in Code.
It's going to be very practical.
Okay.